need motivation watch it top 10 we
believe nation
he's he in the qilin and here's my cake
on his top ten rose to success joy my
advice is this to anyone who announces
they want to be a writer will for a
start nothing stops you you cannot go
around saying you want to be a writer
you can only go around saying I am a
writer all you need is a block of paper
and a pencil
what should you do well my first piece
of advice is this concentrate on the
short story
do not waste the next five years of your
life writing an 800 page block of a
novel that might well be a failure but
your toe in the water gently the short
story is a very difficult form hard to
do well but it is a wonderful laboratory
you can try out all the voices you can
consciously imitate those writers who
seem to be breathing too passionately
down your neck but a good short story or
even a bad short story could only take
you a week three weeks six weeks you
will not have wasted three years number
two show up I always believe that it's
very important to turn up at this test
whether you feel like you don't know
whether you have ideas or not you've got
to have the work ethic that makes you
show up when I've got a piece of work
going and I like to be there like ah ha
past 9 it's very important to close off
all those avenues to the outside world
like the Internet the email the
telephones I switch all those things off
and try and get a solid that have work
done before lunchtime and a solid bit of
work for me would be somewhere between
five and eight hundred words can I'd
feel happy then
if I'd got that down rule number three
love the process I was struck by a
comment you made once about the actual
business of writing and you said that
one of the things that academics often
miss is that and your exact words we're
writing as a self-pleasuring Act which
part from beings like that off-color
image I thought was fascinating because
so many writers describe the actual
business of getting the words down as
are some painful processed do you
actually get fun get kicks out of the
process of getting the words onto the
page I mean I think all writers are
lying when they if they deny some
pleasure in it pleasure principle is
very strong there are those moments when
something goes well in the morning for
half an hour or an hour I try to
describe this experience and I think
everyone's had it we don't have a good
word for it it's a form of happiness I
mean one psychologist called it float
and quite enough total absorption in
trying to do something it could be you
know playing a game of tennis or
gardening or cooking a meal or writing a
novel but it's that wonderful suspension
from time and from the narrative of your
existence when you're simply absolutely
lost to the thing you're doing and you
don't even remember who you are and you
don't even feel any pleasure at the time
and those moments which I think are rare
for all of us but when we only know them
in retrospect is when the doorbell rings
and you pop out of it that you realize
that you have been supremely happy rule
number four keep a journal
you must dedicate yourself to keeping a
journal when I look into my own journals
what fascinates me most about what was
going on in my life thirty years ago are
the things that we would consider the
most mundane
what was I reading who was I talking to
what were the main subjects of
conversation where you're living
what's on your desk who do you love even
what you had for breakfast it doesn't
matter that banality is actually begin
to shine after many years have passed
you don't have to write in it every day
once a week would be fine 500 words a
week doesn't sound much but it really
mounts up that's 25,000 words a year the
terrible thing about life is that most
of it is forgotten and a lot of it is
rich and a lot of that richness can be
retained for future use by an occasional
excursion into an oak also if you want
to cry sake be queuing and other riders
on how to be a successful writer check
out my to 54 writer program the link is
in the description below you cannot go
around saying you want to be a writer
you can only go around saying I am a
writer the reading has to be done if you
don't read as a novelist you're liable
to be hugely influenced by the writers
you haven't read again take you a year
could take you 6 months you might even
get it all down in one delirious month
rule number 5 break routines leaving
space between books is very important
you know as to stop even thinking about
novel writing and get on with knowing
more traveling a bit or for example
before writing solar I was quite happy
attending climate change conferences I
thought that didn't think oh I can it's
because I'm researching a novel this is
because I'd been in conversations with
various scientists and people and they I
got drawn into the subject and step by
step I found myself deeper in and only
later thought I could get a novel out of
this or wanted to write a novel about it
taking journeys is a good way to free
the mind up to be away from home to be
away from home is and away from the
obligations of paying bills of being in
routines breaking routines I think is
crucial rule number six find your
creative process what's the process um I
have a very nice study there's a table
at the table is one of the few things I
ever built myself back in the early 80s
so there's lots of room either side for
writing in longhand and writing in
longhand and working on a computer I
think is perfect I mean so much better
than the mechanical business of the
typewriter so you start in longhand do
you I start in longhand I write notes
and messages and exhortation to myself
can it really be interesting a ring
bound a four green black ink always and
I press medium high and these are notes
or the actual or the actual these are
presages bits of prose and then
sometimes if I'm starting a chapter in
its say chapter four I write the word
contains : and then I think all the
elements that this chapter will contain
as I understand it at that point try out
sentences sometimes I write plots of
novels I've found that one of the most
freeing things you can do as a writer is
to describe the novel which you're never
going to be bothered to write you have
no burdens on you or you write the
opening sentence to a novel that you're
not going to write you feel completely
free and sometimes I've written myself
into a novel that way I started a
tournament that way with a careless
sentence and then a paragraph and then
thought well maybe there's something
here rule number seven who find your
authenticity you need to write through
your influences shake off the voices or
celebrate them I mean but write with a
sense of moving towards
what is truly yours eventually but to do
that you're gonna have to screw up and
you can write five truly terrible short
stories and you will not have lost more
than six months thrill never eat go with
the flow I never know what I'm going to
do next and I think that's one of the
pleasures of a writing career he's just
three years ago I would never have
guessed I was writing this novel five
years ago I'd never would have guessed
writing the children out there is a meta
plot I think of a writer's life which is
the work the five feet in my case it
will be 18 inches but size doesn't
matter of how you got from your first
novel to your last it's a story of your
life in a sense or your creative life
but it cannot be pre-planned so I
honestly don't know at the moment my I'm
so pleasantly empty of what I'll do next
rule number nine learn to say no and I
just wondered how on earth you restore
the stock of ideas how do you live
enough between the novels to replenish
the ideas supply and where and where
does where does hiking fit into the
creative process well I don't feel
prolific so it's odd you should say that
I mean I think of you know Updike or oh
that matter Philip Roth is really
prolific and I do take quite a long time
between Knowles but I make time partly
by saying no to people like you it's
very important often with a real tug on
the heart and it gets harder and harder
to defend that private space I think
this is true for most writers unless
you're a real recluse you're in the
world that world is hungry for ideas
opinions involvement
and a lot of the people who are on the
other end of the line are both
persuasive intelligent and interesting
and it's always a little tug at the
heart to say no but it's absolutely
vital and rule never returned the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
find happiness my friend Christopher
Hitchens once said that one of his
definitions of happiness was to work all
day in the knowledge that he was seeing
an interesting friend in the evening so
sometimes that interesting friend is my
wife or one of my children or one of my
interesting friends but I do like that
sense that there's gonna be food and
wine from about 7:30 on if it fits I'll
go back after dinner maybe to look at
the day's work again I've got a special
bonus coming on how to spark ideas that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that is time for the three-point landing
questions we gotta move from just
watching video to actually taking action
in your life for business here we go
question number one what do you need to
learn to say no to right now number two
when are you most creative and how can
you put that into your daily routine and
number three how can you keep to writing
a journal every day for the next it is I
don't know where ideas come from all if
I knew I had a clear idea of that I'd
have more often I do a lot of hiking and
the rhythm of walking is very amenable I
think to the rhythm of thinking and
that's a good way of letting ideas begin
to take on a bit of life they just pop
out of nowhere really I sometimes I
force an idea just by writing the
opening paragraphs of imaginary novels
imaginary novels in the sense that I
don't have to think for a moment I'm
going to write them
but this is how they would begin if I
did right and that way I can sometimes
trick myself into being interested in
what I've just written and force away in
that way and I've started many novels
like that atonement started exactly in
that way experimental few paragraphs
with with a sense of no obligation and
it's that freedom writing openings or
even middles of novels knowing that you
don't actually have to bother to write
them it gives you a sort of insouciance
you tread in places that you wouldn't
otherwise go that's the closest I could
ever say I have to any method of getting
an idea
if you want to learn how to make it as a
writer check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I often get asked by younger readers
what I would advise if you want to be a
writer this is the way I did it so
that's the only advice I can give